this is the nearest to any sort of kind
of trouble we've actually seen and it's
not really trouble but look at this
we've got yes on that side of the road
and we've got some people with Union
Jack's on this side of the road they are
having a little old shout at each other
but to be honest nothing more than that
you can see the police are lined up
trying to make sure that there is no
trouble there's a big yes rally going on
in the square at the moment these guys
over here you may be able to see I'll
try and go a little bit closer are
clearly going to don't know that's the
Union Jack's
and that are the SS
here is some no thanks supporters some
union s and they are right by a big
valley that's been going on in Georgia
you can see all these guys lined up here
behind police
all shouting going on not much more we
do our policing between them while
trailers as much as people from this
side
another moment it just seems to be there
but doesn't leave anything
do you think you can win what do you
think you're gonna win yes [ __ ] Nobu
autumn am on the run what happened to
mr. know if it's an Oreo indiscreet
krishna is an evolution of team's
efforts and or vacatio and the game has
gone as women TB every country's
development one scotland goes from every
country schools people to last year's
500 miles tanneries in Scotland